>>> WAR OF ARIAEL SMERCONIILADE.
RUSSIAN BILLIONAIRE SAID PUTIN L
DNECT THE 'STRON
R TEAPE THE SITUATION D HE
MOOLY MUCH VERY PA CFFTO
HTN THWESTL ITY.
UKVOLODYMYR TIMATEBILLIO A MONT
ST S OFTICO REPORT THNTG HILL A
RAN PAUL.MEAW THAT A FUTURE AIDI
PACKAGE FOR UKRAINE COULD
SUPPORT PAST
EFFORTS VEF THE PENTAGON
DOESN'ITGH
ED FUNDS.ASE FIRE OR PEACE  SIG
AND RUSSIAN
LO O
ZELENSKYY, THIS WEEK TOLUXEMBOU
THE RUSSIAN INVAON STARTED.
HE ALSEDED TN  AE,CONTROR AMOU
D.
>> Translator: AS OF
TOS UNDER
THL OF OCCUPIERS.
MOKILOMETERS.
THE WAR S  SECRETARY JENS
TENBERG DESCRIBED E
E OF TT
TEDENTEE
HTN NAREHEFOHA PPAD
LOL BECAUS W
SEE IS THAT  NCOMERE
UKRAINIANSREG GH
CO THE 7R G THEIR OWN
UN'SRLAPRYE , N
DYNAMICS ON THE BATTLE
THIS WEEK "THE NEW
PRESIDENT BIDEN PENNED A
EX QUOTE WL
INIANSIT
ADVAOCKET SYEMONTH
TO MORPR S N RAE.ONG HESPA CL
CONFLICTLLHETORIC ROLICT DANGERY
WELL AS THSTAND WOULD ENTAIL SE
T THRAL JAMES STAPH
NA, RISINGBEME
SUPREM
E THW BOOKITNI CONFLICTS AND TH
PUTIN'S
>> I DON'T THINK SO,YOU KNO BEG
TIHAHE   TNG. UDYMYR
Y.
HE T HE WAS A FORMER
COTURNE
WINSTON CHURCHE FIGHTING
SP OF THE UKRAINIAN PEOPLETIEETH
NV
WELL, THEY WERE GREEBOTTLES OF .
RESTIM NCONIM.T E, PUTIN IS THE
POINT , BEFORE WE DE
TH PS N
PERSPECTIVE.
AND  MICHAS OBJECTIVE WA TENTIR
IT.
HE'S TER W I
CONTROOF OF THE COUNTRBEFORES A.
NOW IN COL
ENE
BET NOW Y OF 100%.RA
HAVING SAID L THATSU
WE OUGHTY ABOUT ITY OF THEHAANDA
AFGHANISTAN.
CARE FOR0 YEARS.
AND OH BY THE  WE DN'T
DN WORLD WAR II
N THTTOM LINE, N'T THINK
TIME IS ONDIMIR PUTIN'S
SIDE.
>> OKAY.TH
T CONFLICTS  NOW OTHNFLICTS THAU
WHERE WE WERDIRECTICIPAN BALCAN.
O'VE E HAVE ERMSOPLE ARE ANDMES
DATA, YOU'VE SEEN
S MORE
OT INFLA.D
I'
ES FROM THSE
COUNCIL
GRAIN OF SALT.
UAING INTO AN  I
OUT TO BE RINKF TION BSE.O SURV
FLEE.
THISIS.CO PRICES AT
HOME, FO CRISIAT THE SID PUTIN?
>>TAINLY IT
NG ABOND ADDREIN
SOENERGY FIRST.ITICAL
PROCESS OF THE GREH ISWOULD T
NEEDTOHE ENERGY
EMS AND DETH
WORLD.
EVERYTHING FROMN  TO FUELSU
ANGARKET ESFRANKLTHAT'S GOING
DISCONTINUITERE WILL BE CONTINU
S, IT'S A CO
BUT THAT CAN BE ADSE.
I
TOWER. SENSE OF THENT THAT THER
ANERE  SOLUTION  THAT.
BY WAYTHING UP THE O
H  BIN U NOW AND CONSID
CREATING
OPERIO.
.N INTERNATIONAL RAINIAN  IL?YB.
DO
A WA
APPROACH SOLVING THAT END OFM.,